oh that time has come the time for final
exam work to hard news professionals
compete to find out who has been paying
closer attention to what's going on in
the world this past week our defending
champion this week Fox national
correspondent Peter Doocy is going for
his second win in row his challenger who
was also his challenger for the very
first edition of this segment
his foxes Elizabeth Tran they both join
us on set it's great to see both I know
you know the rules
I do know the rules the future champion
knows the but for the sake of our
viewers just tuning in I'm gonna repeat
them very quickly hands on buzzers I ask
the questions first one to buzz in gets
to answer the question you have to wait
til I finish asking it in order to
answer it each correct answer worth one
point each incorrect gets a point
subtracted from your total best of five
wins you ready it's all ready okay all
right first question which Democratic
senator chastised Hillary Clinton this
week for saying that voters from her
state are looking backward Peter Doocy
I think that that is Heidi how you can
heidi heitkamp now you preface that by
saying I think I thought enough to press
the to ring the alarm
all-stars the buzzer was it Heidi
Heitkamp to the tape we go Missouri
senator Claire McCaskill slamming
Hillary Clinton Missouri voters and I
would draw voters and there are a lot of
reasons they voted for Donald Trump some
of which I completely understand
so the Missouri senator has complete
respectful Missouri voters not for North
Dakota voters stuff I don't know I was
gonna call Mountain I'm like oh I don't
know no I didn't either actually
questions you know this one for sure
Roseanne Barr not a senator says
liberals became too extreme during the
2016 election that's the headline the
other night she confronted a late-night
show host for going too far to the left
who did she confront
want to say Elizabeth Pratt Stephen
Colbert Stephen Colbert did she confront
Stephen Colbert's right now I think
because I know you're you were a very
liberal socially liberal person I didn't
say she because there I said Jamie just
sounded like this s and the J well both
are kind of French names okay so for the
first time in the history of the show we
now have negative 1 to negative that
really yes that's true the first time
that's ever happened always ever done so
we're kind of winning we have three more
someone can get to zero if we try hard
question three there's an object in
space right now it's the size of a
school bus and it's falling to earth
even as we speak there was a slight
chance it could hit the United States
what is that object
Elizabeth Prince Chinese Space Station
it's a Chinese space station is it a
Chinese space station the Chinese space
station most of it will burn up about 10
to 40% of it'll reach the earth taking
the lead at zero are we done we're not
we have two more you can get into
positive territory you can to actually
the game still wide open to more
question number four which former
president has gone viral online after
being filmed dancing enthusiastically at
a family wedding george w bush george w
bush says Peter Doocy roll the tape
please former President George W Bush is
going viral after Terry I saw this
counselor at his nephew's wedding watch
this
[Music]
I don't seem worried about so with 80%
of the segments concluded we are now
zero to zero whatever it's a relative
measure so that where we start the
person who wins this question answers it
correctly wins the segment are you ready
all right final question the Los Angeles
Rams announced this week that an NFL
first their cheerleading squad would see
a major change this season what is that
change what Smith pray male cheerleaders
I don't believe you you know what I
think they should do this from major
league baseball I don't know why is
their cheerleaders a major league
baseball no no Miami does have
cheerleaders but you can cheer from the
stands is the change male cheerleaders
back now with that big change coming to
the NFL for the first time ever men will
be on a cheerleading squad wooden and
Napoleon will be on the sidelines for
the LA Rams you know what I see a second
career for you well now I didn't even
know okay so for extra credit
is this an improvement or the end of
everything we hold dear oh boy I don't
think you are the winner I can't believe
that unseating the season now you're the
winner the coveted Americ wimple mug
commemorating his appearance on this
show Washington Post Eric when people
drink coffee from that and think of us
Elizabeth France that happen gradually
it doesn't it can be any beverage of
your choice including wine we will see
you next week Peter I know that we will
see you again 76 you'd be that Brett
lady you'd be the woman who always comes
back